mentimos
había que estar atento para ver a la
jugadora de baloncesto estadounidense
esposada es el primer día de su juicio a
puerta cerrada en los suburbios de moscú
en la sala una presencia limitado de los
medios de comunicación a petición de la
deportista y su defensa algunos
partidarios también estaban presentes
incluyendo el personal de la embajada de
eeuu en rusia
tuve la oportunidad de hablar con la
señora frenar en la sala lo está
haciendo tan bien como se puede esperar
en estas difíciles circunstancias y me
ha pedido que le transmita que está de
buen humor y que mantiene la oficina
brunet winner tiene 31 años y ha sido
dos veces campeón olímpica y mundial el
pasado mes de febrero la estrella de
baloncesto fue a jugar a rusia durante
la temporada baja estadounidense pero al
llegar al aeropuerto fue detenida con
vaporizadores y un líquido a base de
cannabis según la fiscalía se enfrenta a
una pena de hasta 10 años de prisión
solo puede hablar de los hechos y los
hechos dicen que una atleta destacada
fue detenida en posesión de sustancias
prohibidas que contenían drogas la
legislación rusa si tiene artículos que
castigan estos delitos pero según
washington la jugadora está retenida
injustamente y está pagando el precio de
las pensiones el ruso estadounidenses lo
que moscú niega greener fue detenida
unos días después de la invasión rusa a
ucrania pensando las ya dañadas
relaciones entre las dos naciones en un
tuit el secretario de estado
norteamericano anthony blinken declaró
que hacía del regreso del primer winner
a eeuu una prioridad a la vista de la
legislación rusa en casos similares el
deportista debería esperar una fuerte
condena
también puede usarse como una moneda de
cambio para recuperar prisioneros